是明年五月的婚期，
那是因为我原生家庭比较糟糕，
然后我为了不和他们那一号，
我就和我妈妈现在感觉了联系，
一个人在这边读研，
然后我现在有点犹豫，
不知道现在的男朋友是不是可以结婚的人后也没有一个人可以商量，
所以想过来让龙丽姐姐帮我看看，
我介绍一下我们两个的情况吧，
我是25岁，
是新苑小城市的独生女，
现在在一个二线城市读研，
我是明年毕业，
我读研期间我是自己教学生，
然后收入在一个W左右，
但是不太稳定了，
有的时候寒暑假可能会比这个高一些，
然后没有学生的话，
就一分钱的收入都没有，
我最近买了一个小车，
然后自己再还车贷，
就我的一个情况，
我男朋友是比我大九岁，
他是我现在这个二线城市本地人，
然后是城中村的。
他们家的房子也是城中村的房子，
我们我们现在是住在一起，
是和他父母住上下楼，
然后他们的房子还有其他的租客，
他们家房子一个月租出去大概有个六七千块钱吧，
然后她有两个姐姐，
她的工作不太稳定，
最近一直在找工作，
就是大概是做办公室主任啊，
或者业务经理啊，
这种一个月的工资大概也就是六七千块钱，
我我们已经同居了大概一年了，
其实我一刚开始初中找对象是想想找一个条件好一些的，
然后我和他刚认识的时候，
他经济状况是表现的很好的样子，
才开了一个奔驰，
我后来才知道不是他的，
刚开始也没有跟我说不是他的，
但是我发现的时候就是感觉我们两个已经有感情了，
对我也挺好的，
然后这个事儿我也没有很深究，
后来我才知道他还有一些债务，
是因为他之前做生意被骗了，
我和他在一起将近这两年的时间，
他一直都在还债，
他和我坦白了他的债务以后，
我们在一起的开支基本上都是我在承担，
然后他父母是管着我们吃喝呀，
水电费呀这一些的。
这他对我的情绪价值还是给的挺足的，
也很包容我，
很支持我，
我们同济这段时间我们的性格呀，
还有我生活习惯呀，
我觉得都挺合得来的，
他的工作也挺努力的，
夏天的时候他白天去上班，
晚上还去跑代驾，
因为他的工资都是还债了嘛，
跑代驾一晚上挣的100多都给我，
大概就是这么一个情况，
他总共欠了多少你知道吗？
总共当时是欠了七八十万，
然后他家里面给还，
加上他自己前些年也还了一些，
现在他跟我说是还有3万，
如果我们打算明年5月结婚的话，
他是结婚之前是能还完的，
他爸爸妈妈性格怎么样啊，
爸爸妈妈性格还挺不错的，
就是嗯，
一家人都是挺讲道理，
很好沟通的那种，
就是有什么事都能沟的了。
两个姐姐都嫁了吧，
嗯，
对，
孩子都上小学了，
嫁的远不远啊，
会时常回来吗？
有一个嫁的比较远，
一个挺近的，
嗯，
咱们两个姐姐相处的怎么样啊？
是一家人，
性格都蛮好的。
其实我现在主要犹豫的就是我。
我最近因为给我自己，
我还在读研嘛，
给我自己交学费，
然后还车大贷，
车的保险，
我最近就是经济压力也比较大，
然后我每天交学生，
我自己还面临毕业要写论文啊，
还要找工作，
这些方面的压力就是把我压的有点抑郁和焦虑的感觉，
然后我身边的朋友也都在和我说，
如果我找一个经济条件好一点的男生就没有这些问题了，
其实我身边也有条件好一点的男生在追我，
但是我会觉得说他们只是喜欢我很好的这一面，
因为我在外人面前表现的确实是很开朗，
性格很好的一个女生，
但是我自己知道，
我可能就是过起日子来就不是一个情绪很稳定的人，
所以说我会觉得他们可能不能接受我这个负面的，
但是我现在男朋友，
他可以说我就不特别想no no nono,
没有人能接受他现在可以替再忍，
或许在权衡利弊，
如果你的态度是说我要找一个人来包容我的坏脾气的话，
这个人一定不行，
你们都还没有孩子了，
他还是。
你的软饭，
说白了他还花了你的钱，
她或许现在还能忍一忍，
诶，
实际实实在在把你骗进门呢，
她还能忍一忍，
对不起啊。
龙玉姐可能有一点激动，
就是我们所有的女孩子，
不要上来就觉得我就是脾差，
我就是情绪不稳定，
找一个人来包容我的坏脾气，
我找一个人来包容我的缺点，
不是的，
我们的人生路还很长，
我是先认识到我脾气差，
认识到我自己情绪不稳定，
我要去学会分析我为什么会脾气差，
为什么会情绪不稳定，
原因是什么，
点是什么，
我找到那个原因，
找到那个点，
我的首要任务是把我自己修炼成一个更好的伴侣，
一个更好的对象，
而不是将就我那么差的条件，
我去找一个人来包养我，
不是这样子，
一定不是这样子，
没有人可以包容坏脾气的，
而且性格极端的就是易怒的，
没有人可以包容这样的人，
你的现在这个状态是，
第一你自己是研究生，
第二你自己赚钱能力很好，
第三你很年轻，
第3个是你的手上的就是王牌，
按照你手上这3个王牌的话，
那我非常客观的说，
你现在找的这个男朋友，
他是配不上你的，
他配不上你的。
点在于什么？
因为他现在已经34岁了，
他等于是一事无成，
一分钱存款没有，
还有负债，
因为你说那个房租，
那个不是他打下来的江山，
那是他父母打下来的江山，
而从个人条件，
从他自身来看的话，
他就是一个34岁，
这里不错，
没有正经工作，
对吧？
要房没有，
要车没有，
要存款没有。
嗯，
就是从这个角度来说的话，
我认为他是追不上你的，
但是咱们反过来比是家庭，
就是说你和你妈妈为什么会闹掰，
诶，
我妈妈她想就是，
反正我是从小就是被带长大的，
我父亲就是因为家里面天天鸡飞狗跳的，
然后就从我小学就走了，
就没有回来这么分居了，
但是没有理你，
如果是这样的话，
可能你是在你妈妈养育你的过程当中，
没有好好的爱你，
没有好好的给你安全感，
你现在形成了自己一个容易发怒，
容易情绪不稳定的这样一个状态，
我可以这么理解和推导吗？
我不太经常发怒，
就是比较敏感，
会闹小情绪，
这我情绪还算比较稳定，
因为我一直在调自己的心理啊，
性格呀，
我一直在不断的提升，
我自己性格其实也没有很差，
我就是内心可能有一点自卑吧，
就是害怕别人不会包容我，
就是我在别人面前，
因为我属于那种讨好型人格，
我和条件好一点的男生在一块儿，
我就会觉得就是有点天然代表小心翼翼的那种感觉。
首先第1点你能够读到研究生，
就表示你自己是拥有很好的学习能力的，
就是上进的这么一个能力的。
其次你能做到和你的那个不好的妈妈，
就是虐待你的妈妈，
你能做到和他断绝关系，
证明你是勇敢的，
你有决心的，
你是能够保护自己的，
你现在已经具具备了这些生命当中最可贵的你的气质，
最可贵的一些东西，
那你现在如果说你要选择人生伴侣的话，
一定记住龙飞姐这个逻辑对你会特别有帮助，
一定是先把自己修炼成一个好的伴侣，
你再去找一个好的伴，
那现在目前来看的话，
你要说这个人能不能。
能凑合过日子，
但能不能达到你想要的生活，
能不能实现你一个从坏的妈妈手里逃离出来，
自己又努力考上研究生，
而且自己又赚钱能力那么强，
而且你还那么年轻，
你又那么上进，
能不能达到你所向往的那种生活？
我认为可能达不到。
啊，
对，
是不太能的，
因为我一直都自己很上进，
很努力才走到今天这个程度的，
我觉得压力特别大的时候，
我也会质疑我自己现在的这个选择。
以上就是龙飞姐给你讲的这些，
你已经很棒了，
你能够脱离你妈妈的那个掌控，
能够自己那么强大，
且自己考上了研究生，
而且你在读书期间，
你就一个月能挣1万多块钱，
你想你多棒。
多优秀，
现在就是跟他说，
我说要不然先别结婚了，
我就是先把婚期推掉了，
我不想再考虑一下，
但是我们现在都已经开始装修房子了，
别说你想考虑一下，
你说我现在太压力太大了，
我又要那个写论文，
我又要毕业，
我又要找工作，
我根本没有心思准备这些东西，
我觉得我们现在都已经开始装修了，
分手是不是不太合适？
嗯，
他娶你要装修，
请问他娶张三要不要装修？
他娶李四要不要装修？
你少给意见，
你别要说装修成你想要的样子，
结果你又不要人家了就行，
好，
我明白了，
这样啊，
嗯，
拜，
我不知道我直播间的姐妹们，
包括兄弟们听完了之后感觉怎么样，
实话实说，
这男的对吧，
34岁了。
就一无所有，
还有债务，
还是这个女孩的，
还养着她呢，
你怎么说？
尤其这女孩才25岁，
人家研究生，
人家读书期间一个月能挣1万多块钱啊，
六七千块钱是吧？
你读书期间人家自己就把自己的生活安的挺明白，
而且这女孩她只要能够从她的原生家庭脱离出来，
她的妈妈就彻底以后不来往了，
没有原生家庭的拖累，
没有原生家庭拖后腿，
这女孩很容易找啊，
你看刚才那个姑娘，
她其实人也挺善良的，
她说不是都已经装修了，
是不是有点不太好，
你琢磨呀，
她是不是娶谁都得装修，
娶你那他自己住是不是也得装修？
啊，
这个不是为你付出的成本，
你要记住。